all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here with me Darius a great place for us
to start is liquidity and asset markets
it is the heartbeat of the financial
system what's going on with liquidity in
relationship to these asset markets yeah
absolutely man it's great to be back so
uh I'll start by saying you know I feel
like we've been talking about liquidity
you know pretty much Ad nauseam for the
past few months uh specifically with
respect to the fact that we've seen and
are currently observing this negative
inflection in global liquidity I recall
that you know our liquidity proxy
globally accounts for the global central
bank balance sheets Global broad money
supply and Global FX reserves uh minus
gold and that number has been trading
lower albeit modestly uh in recent
months and so what we wanted to do is to
sort of uh add some analysis to you know
our view that hey we might see a
correction this summer in asset markets
as a function of that inflection
liquidity and the reality is once we
perform that work it really doesn't
suggest that we should see a correction
so I'll start with the first chart where
we show uh the relationship between the
S P 500 and our Global liquidity as
measured by those indicators and what
you can see is that the correlation is
very tight when you regress it on a
level spaces in fact liquidity explains
97 of the level of the S P 500 when you
look at the r squared on that but we go
to the second chart and we regress it on
a percentage change basis so how does
liquidity explain the rate of change of
the s p in any given interval and we see
that it only explains about 12 percent
of the rate of change in that second
chart we perform that same analysis for
Bitcoin as well looking at a trailing
10-year study so the s p study was since
the start of 2009 looking at the Bitcoin
study on slide three here we see that
liquidity explains 77 of the level of
Bitcoin but when we regress Bitcoin
against the you know sort of the rate of
change of the two indicators we see that
it explains about zero percent of the
change in Bitcoin and so the summary of
these four charts is to suggest that hey
look you might have informed views about
liquidity but on a short intermediate
term time frame you can't necessarily
take those views and extract related to
asset markets in sort of the linear way
that I think we've all been conditioned
to uh in recent years so when you go
ahead and you look at that liquidity a
big thing is it could lead to inflation
or it could lead to disinflation you all
have continued to point out the
disinflation that's showing up in things
like the pce report describe what you
saw in the main numbers yeah absolutely
so uh with respect to uh inflation I did
want to talk about inflation
specifically out of that PC report that
we got on Friday because to me I think
the return of inflation as a topic is
what's going to cause the markets to go
down and we're not quite there yet so I
think it's fake to say that it's we're a
comfortable punting on that view that we
would see a correction asset markets at
least until we get to August if not
September because that's when I think
that we might start to see firmer
inflation data certainly relative to
consensus expectations which are calling
for a recession to begin in Q3 which we
obviously disagree with we've long
disagree with that view we've been of
the view that recession would commence
in late 2023 or early 2024 since fall of
2022 so that this hasn't changed on our
side so just getting into the PC report
on Slide Five we show core PC inflation
and super core PC inflation the bottom
panel which is a core Services PC X
housing and so what we saw on the PC
report is we saw a little bit of a
downtick in core pce which is the fed's
preferred inflation measure that's the
top panel there the decelerated modestly
on a year over year basis of 4.6
decelerated modestly on a three-month
annualized basis to 4.1 percent which is
the lowest point we've seen since
December in that time series the second
uh if you look at the second indicator
um the second panel rather we saw a much
bigger deceleration in super core uh PC
inflation uh to 4.5 year over year but a
much bigger deceleration three months
annualized to 3.8 percent that's the
lowest Sprint in that time series that
we've seen since November so we are
continuing to see these very positive
outcomes on the inflation front and
that's been one thing that's been
supportive of asset markets is these
negative persistent negative uh
inflation surprises we've also had
persistently positive economic surprises
as well so if you look at that from a
double whammy perspective with growth
surprising to the upside inflation
surprise into the downside and obviously
both of those Dynamics have been very
positive for asset markets in the first
half of the year we expect they're
likely to continue to be positive at
least through July potentially into
August uh but then after after that we
might start to see some inflation data
firm up
and so
when we think of the business cycle
inflation is one of these weird things
because I keep coming back to this idea
of inflation is driving price is higher
but now what we have is we have business
owners that are guessing what is going
to happen in some way it's like playing
a pin the tail in the donkey but the
donkey's moving and so you're trying to
figure out like hey what what should I
actually charge for this thing and if I
change all my prices I gotta go print my
menus and now all of a sudden in two
three four months if the prices are
supposed to change again am I gonna go
print my menus all over again or you
know whatever the thing is for your
specific type of business how do you
think about that inflation in the
business like I'm like what are business
owners actually doing on the ground in
response to uh these kind of
inflationary movements yeah you have a
great that's a great way to pose the
question because the reality is
inflation is a process it's not just you
know we receive inflation as Financial
Market participants as you know this
number that gets reported by you know
various agencies or if you you know
things look at other indicators you know
they may not be um government related
but the reality is is there is a there's
a systematic process of inquiring
information from acquiring information
from the economy business owners and
ultimately having to decide whether or
not they're going to be able to you know
pass those costs on to their ultimate
customers and what we see here in this
chart here on slide six you know what
we're showing in this analysis are the
various Cycles within the economy and
we're trying to see how they sort of
behave in and around recession so the
chart on the left shows the median
trailing 10-year Delta adjusted z-score
for various indicators that represent
each of these uh Cycles so there's a
basket of indicators that represent the
housing cycle that that basket of
indicators on a median basis tends to
break down below Trend right around 18
months prior to recession that's the x's
on these on these plots here the orders
the basket of indicators that represents
the order cycle breaks down ahead of
below Trend it's right around kind of
eight months ahead of a recession the
production and profits indicators tend
to break down on a median basis right
around you know kind of six months ahead
of a recession and the employment
indicators tend to break down on a
median basis right around the start of
recession or zero months and what we see
is the light blue line there in the
chart on the left the x marks the spot
on the light blue line is six to eight
months after the recession starts and so
the that's a long way to way of saying
we we should not expect inflation to
break down materially below Trend until
we're well into the recession process
which again we believe starts in late
2023 early 2024 the earliest and so
that's our that's kind of along with the
way of saying
we've gotten a lot of disinflation we've
gotten a lot of Immaculate disinflation
and ultimately as investors we got to
start to prepare our minds and
ultimately our portfolios for the
possibility that inflation really starts
to get sticky in the second half of the
Year leading up to recession because
history suggests that it's it's very
unlikely that we're going to continue to
see this Immaculate this inflation so we
basically you're saying that there's a
high probability or a probability that
we're going to get disinflation once
that kind of culminates and uh you know
ends then we get this re-inflation that
starts to occur but it's a re-inflation
into a recession which may not be kind
of the way that people intuitively think
of uh the the relationship between
inflation and a recession yeah no
totally I mean typically you tend to see
things like core pce or wage inflation
Peak during or even slightly after
recessions conclude you know history
shows that it's very rare actually you
know going back to that chart five where
we show the deceleration and core PC the
deceleration we're observing the
supercore PC it's very rare that we
actually see those outcomes ahead of
session in fact if you look at the core
PC time series throughout all the
recessions that we have I think it
started in the 1950s there's only one
observation in of deceleration leading
up to recession that's the 1981-82
recession all other observations core PC
was either flat or accelerating into the
start of a recession so in our in our
view we are going to start to see more
sticky inflation outcomes in the second
half of the year and part of the reason
for that is base effects right if you
look at June data that we were going to
get I believe on July 12th uh in a
couple of weeks the base effects for
June are actually really tough I.E so we
should see another month of really you
know sharp disinflation uh in the month
of June for the June inflation data but
once we get past June the base effects
curve really starts to level off so it's
very likely that we start to see year
over year measures of inflation kind of
bottom out wherever they are you know
after the June data points so that's
something that I need to put on we want
to put on investors Radars because again
we see a very modest negative inflection
liquidity I don't think that modest
negative inflation liquidity is enough
in and of its own right to cause a
correction and across asset markets
that's that that's what the data that we
just highlighted on the correlation
studies suggests however I think what
will cause a correction in asset markets
is the realization that hey inflation is
going to be sticky the fed's going to
have to do more the ECB is going to have
to do more all these other central banks
are going to have to do more just like
we saw with the Bank of Canada and the
bank of Reserve Bank of Australia
recently
talk about home prices I know you've got
a chart here that that shows that those
are re-accelerating
yeah absolutely so that's all I mean
talk about sticky inflation right so we
got uh data this week from uh FIFA and s
p coralogica Schiller in terms of
national home prices and what we see is
on a three-month annualized basis here
in chart eight the top two panels fifth
a home prices which are the single month
I think the data's through um through
the month of May is it accelerating on
it plus 8.7 percent on a three-month
annualized basis it's sort of bottomed
in the first half of this year and it's
now really starting to accelerate the
CoreLogic k-shiller data which is a
three-month moving average of of that
month so it includes uh May uh April or
sorry May April and March that date is
up 4.4 but it's eventually going to
catch up to the FIFA data and that's an
issue because when you look at the
bottom two panels we show the CBI
shelter component of CPI that's
compounding at 6.2 percent through myth
annualized uh pce index on housing it's
compounding at 6.2 percent through
methanolize what this bottoming in the
top two panel suggests is we're probably
going to bottom in housing inflation
let's call it two three quarters from
now at levels that are extremely
inconsistent with the fed's two percent
inflation mandate and that's concerning
in the context of everything we're
talking about in terms of the fed you
know ultimately having to do a lot more
just really kind of Offset you know the
the the you know the impulse to
inflation that we continue to see going
out of the housing market and two out of
the fiscal Authority don't forget we're
running a record non-war non-recession
budget deficit here in the U.S economy
it's two trillion dollars about eight
percent of GDP and that number you know
it's going to come down a little bit
over the next 12 months or so as a
function of the um of the debt ceiling
but it wasn't really they took big
haircuts to that number so we're going
to continue to see a lot of inflationary
pressures in the economy and that's
that's an issue in the context of slide
seven here uh where we show um the uh
the ISM Manufacturing uh supplier
delivery times index we show the ism
services in the red bot line the supply
delivery times index there in the black
line it's Global Freight rates and what
we see from these indicators is that
they're pretty much back at levels that
are consistent with two percent
inflation right like we're not going to
get anymore or Immaculate disinflation
from the transitory elements of
inflation that were caused by either the
pandemic or the fiscal response to the
pandemic you know so that's that's a
long way one way of saying I think we're
getting close to the end of the good
part of the the inflation battle and
then the real work is going to begin you
know kind of in the second half of this
year really into the early part of next
year
um in terms of the FED reaction function
and really it's not just a Fed it's the
ecbs the bank of England it's a lot of
central banks globally
Darius we are not in an official War but
an unofficial uh proxy wars as being
waged I'll leave it at that uh in terms
of
um
the NASDAQ up 32 to start the year
fastest start since 1983. bitcoin's up
85 percent though to start the year
which is almost triple what the NASDAQ
is doing when you think of inflation uh
I think everyone always thinks about the
inflation of uh the consumer goods but
also obviously there's inflationary
pressures and asset prices if you take
it to the extreme the Zimbabwe stock
market is the best performing stock
market of the year so far 800 percent
and I think of this as like Zimbabwe is
just a magnification and kind of the
extreme of what's actually happening in
the US as well uh is that true or or is
there some other kind of nuancer that's
important for people to wrap their heads
around no no yeah I think that's that's
safe to say right like don't forget like
we are the world's Sovereign currency so
we can't allow ever to allow ourselves
to be Zimbabwe that will cause so much
you know economic you know hardship for
many many billions of people in the
world so I don't think we're headed to
that ultimate end game but we are some
version of that right you have again
we're running a record non-war
non-budget deficit a budget deficit of
minus eight percent of GDP and we're not
in a recession
right like what's that number going to
when we get into a recession and the tax
receipts start to fall and and you know
mandatory spending starts to rise and so
you know we are on this sort of path
towards populace right like Donald Trump
figured this out you know you can make
the case to Joe Biden kind of
piggybacked on that and whoever's going
to be president after that they're going
to piggyback on it more because we're in
this fourth turning era where the
response to economic hardship is just
throw money at the the population it's
not austerity you know when I started in
this business you know maybe 15 years
ago it was all about austerity and
cutting budget deficits now it's like
you get the debt ceiling and then you
barely even shave off the top of the you
know the shave off Crumbs from the
budget deficit so I think that is where
we're headed and this is why central
banks have become such active
participants in government Global
sovereign debt markets and they're going
to continue to be such active
participants over the long period of
time that doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to be linearly supplying
liquidity at every interval going
forward because obviously as we talked
about global liquidity has inflected
lower in recent months but it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're you know
they're they're going to be part of this
game for a really long period of time so
one thing that really concerns me
about the bond market but it's actually
very bullish for things like Bitcoin
very bullish for things like the NASDAQ
and stocks is the fact that the bond
market is currently starting at a very
you know Kind of Perfect Price if you
look at term premium the bond market
they're deeply negative if you look at
where inflation expectations are in the
bond market they're all anchored around
two percent whether you look at break
evens or inflation swap curves and so
the reality is
I think the Bond markets got this wrong
and I think the fun flow story is out of
bonds into stocks into the digital
assets like Bitcoin I think that's going
to be something that's got a very long
tail to it um as a context of the
political response to uh you know
populism things of that nature I tend to
agree and uh it feels like with Bitcoin
specifically there is this uh
intersection of uh different interests
right you have obviously the disciplined
monetary policy you have all the
geopolitical nonsense uh you have
censorship you have uh seizures
happening all over uh the uh the world
um but also you have this feeling of
people saying hey I need an alternative
and it could be an alternative currency
it could be an alternative to store
value it could be an alternative uh
Viewpoint and I think one of the the
most interesting things is uh it's kind
of something different to all these
other people right so like what Bitcoin
means to me may be different than you or
then somebody sitting in another country
or on another situation and so
um if that is true let's just take all
of those assumptions as true what else
fits into that bucket and what I find
interesting is it's not just Bitcoin
there are plenty of stocks that people
look at that again they may not look at
them as a currency or as a store value
type thing but there's a stock that may
be different things to different people
right and so obviously those start to uh
to benefit as well and then if you go
and you look at things like Commodities
right there's a lot of people right now
uh in my opinion who are looking at
various Commodities and one person's
buying it for reason a and another
person's buying it for reason B uh but
at the end of the day if the underlying
currency that it is denominated in is
devalued somebody needs to spend more
dollars to buy that asset in the future
than they do today and the longer the
time period the more the dollar gets
devalued and so I'm always fascinated by
the studies that show the U.S stock
market if you basically take out the
change in the money supply how it's kind
of like flat
yeah yeah totally right yeah if you if
you just regress the uh go back to those
regression charts if you just rebase the
stock market in global liquidity hasn't
done anything it's like 97 level it
means it hasn't done anything and and
it's kind of this weird thing where uh
you can go back pretty far and it still
hasn't done anything and so in some
weird way uh you know we have assets
that go up because we have a central
bank that obviously helps on the global
liquidity front but if we didn't have
that how much real value is getting
created in the world
that's a good question man I mean that's
that's a very deep long you know longer
term kind of like deep thought topic but
the reality is think about think about
the error we just left right they kept
interest rates at zero for a really long
period of time they were constantly
expanding their balance sheet and taking
risk out of the global financial sector
forcing investors like us further and
further out on the risk Spectrum to you
know find replace that replacement
assets and the reality is that's how you
got you know the Ubers and the Netflix
and all these sort of formerly
unprofitable companies now that are
extremely profitable because they were
able to you know grow their size of
their business and take a ton of market
share so you know that that was an
outcrop a monetary policy you know
creating all that Supply particularly
out of the tech you know kind of tech
oriented type of type world and so you
know I think we've left that world you
know certainly from an interest rate
perspective I I really struggle to see
how the FED is going to ever be able to
take interest rates back towards you
know where they were in that in that
previous regime and the reality because
there's so much latent inflation
pressure in the system you know we run
um you know we call a secular inflation
model it's got 20 different features
that are highly correlated or highly
co-integrated to the under the unit root
of um of inflation and the reality is
that that model suggests we're probably
going to see you know persistently like
you know Three percentish core pce
inflation over the next decade uh in
terms of the the mean of the the time
series and so if we have three percent
core PC inflation over the next decade
it presents the FED with a very
interesting choice do they revise their
inflation Target to from two percent to
three percent or do they just constantly
fight against what is likely to happen
in the economy and constantly be
fighting against you know the the latent
inflation pressure in the economy trying
to get to two percent I happen to think
they're eventually going to Pivot to
three percent they're not going to Pivot
to three percent anytime soon because
Jay Powell and is you know he's seven
years old he wants his legacy to be that
he didn't you know let the inflation
Genie out of the bottle but the reality
is he might not have a choice because if
the unemployment rate right now it's at
3.7 percent at 5.7 unemployment rate or
you know heaven forbid it's 6.7 which
would be a very you know low
unemployment rate to low level for them
on plumber rate to get to in a recession
I think the median is around seven and a
half percent in recessions in terms of
the peak unemployment rate if it gets to
6.7 300 basis point higher than where it
is today
did I ever hearing all this tough talk
on the Dot Plot and all that stuff that
nonsense these guys you know I mean they
panicked already with inflation running
at four or five percent core pce in
terms of bailing out the banks this year
you know Financial stability and
economic stability will very much
dominate their thought process as we
move forward in time and so ultimately
we know the liquidity is coming uh it
just might not come you know very very
soon Darius where can we send people to
find you on the internet uh either on
Twitter or find out more about 42 macro
yeah I appreciate you man so yeah
definitely come check us out I got
Twitter at uh 42 macro weather that's
our public Twitter also of our private
Twitter as well for our 40 tobacco uh
subscribers uh 42 macro aware and then
come definitely check us out 42
macro.com uh you get to get all this
research as often as you want to get
given my uh dry voice and not having any
uh water here this is my Prime
opportunity to say as an investor in
liquid death I should have had some
liquid death water sitting here
I I appreciate you coming on and we'll
definitely do it again in the future I
appreciate you brother man you be good